maryland gop congressional candidate kim
klaxic whose first digital ad went viral
released a sequel yesterday in which he
continues to hold
well baltimore's democratic leaders
accountable for their failures
particularly to the
african-american community take a look i
walk the streets of baltimore and see
what could be i want you to see what i
see
i see baltimore that picks up trash
there are piles of garbage
all around baltimore it makes life
unsafe for our families
i'll work with city leaders to get
baltimore's solid waste bureau the
resources it needs to take out the trash
and on friday she joined the ever
important hard-hitting news show the
view where she had a heated exchange
with co-hosts joyless joy behar after
criticizing her
for wearing blackface it ended quickly
take a look
is this joy speaking of the same joy
this year i enjoyed that
paraded around in blackface not too long
ago come on joe i don't think you should
be asking those questions
i am excuse me excuse me the black
community
had my back they know that that
community had fun
here with more maryland gop
congressional candidate kim klasek
herself
civil rights attorney oh man
leo 2.0 he won the poll fair and square
i was wrong friday i humbly apologize i
don't like losing i'm s
i'm not sick of winning uh but you win
leo
uh i'm hannitized where did you get that
hat i don't even have i'm hannitized
i never saw a hat like that before uh
all right kim let me go to baltimore
what the third highest spending per
capita per student in the world
13 is it true 13 public schools where
not a single child is proficient in math
in baltimore
that is absolutely true sean and you can
add to that we actually have
more data that came out that said 9 out
of 10 black male students
do not read at grade level in baltimore
city so we have a problem
with our education that's why i'm a
proponent for school choice
we have a problem with career
opportunities we lack them we don't have
anything there
that's why i'm really pushing for
president trump's opportunity zones
in baltimore city he's already invested
75 billion
into other cities that democrats have
left neglected so we need that in
baltimore
and then of course we talk about the
importance of family structure you know
there's just these simple things that we
can do
to drive down the crime and violence and
get people economic opportunities and
that's what we need to do
you know leo i see this and yet
democrats get elected you know liberal
democrats
have been running states blue states and
cities into the ground they fail on law
order safety security education those
are the two most important things that
they ought to be doing right you're 100
right school choice is a civil rights
issue of the day
it breaks the poverty cycle and what kim
is doing
if kim wins this election it will break
the
democratic stranglehold on black voters
and i gotta go walk those streets in
baltimore because this election is
key kim needs to win this election it
will send a message
a message to the democratic powers
structure
that the blacks have broken away and kim
is really
the key to breaking that strangle hole
on blacks
by the democratic party and that's why
they're nervous about kim and one last
point
joe joy behar the black community have
your back
that's what i'm talking about sean they
think of us as monolithic
i don't have joy behar's back kim does
it and for her to say that she
has the black communities back that is
insulting that's a joel
biden statement and it's very very
insulted
kim you're running these hard-hitting
ads and you're saying this is a
institutional failure there's no safety
there's no security there's nothing but
poverty
decades of of liberal democratic rule
um how is your message resonating
yeah so so far so good you know it's
like you know a little bit of the the
trump syndrome we have some people that
don't want to admit it out loud and we
understand that because of the backlash
but we have people out there seven days
a week uh knocking on doors canvassing
and then five days a week we're actually
registering voters
uh believe it or not in these areas
especially in these dangerous
neighborhoods in west baltimore
there are a lot of people that just
aren't registered to vote and so we're
just telling them like
you've got to be involved in this
process you know your future your
children's future they all depend on it
so so far so good just like we saw
there's a nine point swing for president
trump
i had a nine point swing in my special
election and i think we're going to do
even better this time around
will the polls that show
african-americans and hispanic americans
moving towards donald trump will they
translate into votes
in now 43 days leo 2.0
i'll tell you right now yes because look
michael moore made a comment
that joe biden has taken blacks in
michigan for granted there's been a
whole mindset shot and it's being broken
with people like kim
like myself the democrats are very
nervous because
blacks are moving towards the republican
party
like the hispanics and that's all it
takes is to go in those battleground
states with more blacks voting for trump
i need to be in michigan
and i need to be in baltimore so kim
wins that seat